البدايه بتطورات الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا حيث اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
سيطره قواتها بشكل كامل على السوليدار
الليله الماضيه وهو الامر الذي نفته
اوكرانيا واكدت ان القتال ما زال دائما في
المدينه
لمتابعه اخر التطورات على الارض ينضم
الينا منا كلام تورز مراسل الجزيره عمر
الحاج ايضا من موسكو مراسلتنا رانيا
عمر من هذا النفي الاوكراني
الاوكرانيه
القوات الروسيه قد تمت تمت سيطرتها على
مدينه سوريا
القوات الروسيه التي كما قالت في بيانها
زوجت بخيره مقاتلنار في هذه المعركه وقالت
انها ما تزال تسعى لاعاده الاستقرار
للخطوط الدفاعيه للقوات الاوكرانيه هناك
مشيره الى ان وحدات كثيره ومن اسلحه
مختلفه تشترك في هذه المعركه سواء قوات
الخاصه او من سلاح المظليين او حتى من
وحدات اخرى في الجيش الاوكراني ايضا ان
الامر ليس فقط في سوريا
الذي اعادت اليها الاشتراكات مره اخرى
وقوت اوكرانيه تقول انها همم تتصدى
الهجمات الروسيه
في تلك الجبهه دون ان تعلق كذلك الامر
الاخبار الروسيه والحديث الروسي عن
السيطره على مدينه اوبتنا بلده صغيره في
الجهه الجنوبيه من مدينه باخمد القوات
الاوكرانيه تحدثت بالعموم انها تصدت لكل
الهجمات التي شنتها روسيا في تلك المنطقه
كذلك الامر القوات الاخرانيه تقول انها ما
تزال تشنها هجماتها في الجهه الشماليه
تحديدا في محور الصفاتوفا كريمينا ولكن من
الملاحظه ان القوات الروسيه وسعه نطاقه
هجومها في هذه المنطقه سفيان بعد ان بدات
بارسال وقوات وقوات مشاه وقوات خاصه
واستطناه باتجاه الجبهات التي كان القتال
فيها يتركز فقط على القصف والقصف المتبادل
بين الجانبين تحدث عن الجبهات الجنوبيه في
مقاطعه دنياس في المناطق التي ما تسال
خاطئه لسياره القوات الاوكرانيه سواء اف
دي افكها حتى مارينكا والغدار وفي الجنوب
باقي المدن الاوكرانيه البعيده عن الجبهه
كذلك الامر تعرضت لقصف من قبل القوات
الروسيه
ايضا هنا في اكرامتوس وكذلكوستنط نيفكا
التي استهدفت في او وقت سابق القوات
الاوكرانيه والمسؤول الاوكرانيون يعترفون
بصعوبه الاوضاع في سوريا ولكنهم مصرون على
الروايه التي ما فاتها نعي عن عمليات
العسكريه والقتال ما يزالوا مستمرا وانهم
يوقعون خسائر كبيره في صفوف القوات
الروسيه قد اجتمع مع قادته الضباط الجيش
وقياده الاركان وناقش ناقش ما يجري همم في
سوريا
حول هذا الصدد
ضروري يا برنس
حللنا بالتفصيل القرارات والتعزيزات
المطلوبه كما نقشنا توريد الاسلحه
والذخيره للقوات اشكر المظليين من اللواء
السابع والسبعين الجوي ومقاتلي اللواء 46
في سوريا دار الذين يتمسكون بمواقعهم
ويلحقون خسائر كبيره بالعدو
ابقى معنا عمر نذهب الى موسكو ورانيا هناك
رانيا هل من جديد في الموقف والتصريحات
القادمه من موسكودا
حتى هذه اللحظه هو الاعلان الرسمي من قبل
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن السيطره الكامله
على مدينه ساردار والتي تحمل اهميه عسكريه
واستراتيجيه بالنسبه للقوات المسلحه
الروسيه فضلا عن ان السيطره على هذه
المدينه يفتح الطريق امام القوات الروسيه
للتقدم شمالا ونحو الشمال الشرقي باتجاه
مدينتي كراما طارس فضلا عن ذلك وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه تؤكد على نقطتين اهميه
مهمتين فيما يتعلق بالسيطره على دار تتحدث
عن ان همم هذا النجاح الذي حققته همم
القوات الروسيه حسب وصفها اولا يقطع
امدادات القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه نحو
مدينه باخمه وايضا يسمح للقوات الروسيه
باحكام همم تطويق ما تبقى من قوات
اوكرانيه في مدينه باخ متولي الاستراتيجيه
بحسب لتصريحات وزاره الدفاع الروسيه كل
ذلك ياتي زي ما انتم شايفين الماء اعلان
القوه الانفصاليه في مقاطعه ادانياسك عن
همم محاصره القوات الاوكرانيه ايضا في
مدينه دانياس بشكل كامل بحيث تم احكام
تطويق هذه القوات في هذه المدينه فضلا عن
ذلك هناك حديث عن ان معارك تجري حاليا في
المناطق الشماليه والشرقيه في المناطق
الشماليه الحديث يدور عن معارك عنيفه في
منطقه في بلده كريسماس في الجنوب من مدينه
معارك همم دائره وتم الاعلان عن السيطره
على منطقه استراتيجيه في المعنى العسكري
بالنسبه للقوات المسلحه وهي السيطره على
بلده همم فضلا عن ذلك وهناك عمليات تمشيط
حاليا تقوم بتنفيذها قواتنا المشاركه بشكل
اساسي في المعارك في هذه الجبهه تمشيط
الكره والبلدات التي تم السيطره عليها من
الجانب من الجهه الجانب من الج شرقيه من
مدينه باخموت ويتم تعزيز مواقع القوات
المسلحه الروسيه في هذه المنطقه فضلا عن
ذلك كل ذلك جاء بالتزامن مع اعلان الجانب
الروسي عن تدمير قوات الاحتياط التي
ارسلتها القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه من
مقاطعه خرسون باتجاه مدينه سلدار لدعم
قواتها في هذه المدينه امس تم تدمير هذا
اللواء اللواء واحد وستون الذي تم ارساله
لدعم القوات الاوكرانيه في سليدار بشكل
كامل بحيث تم القضاء على نحو 300 عسكري
اوكراني خلال هذه العمليه وللوقوف على
تواصل ما يجري حاليا في سالدار ليتابع ما
قالته وزاره الدفاع الروسيه في هذا الشهر
السيطره الكامله على مدينه سوليدار تسمح
بقطع امدادات القوات الاوكرانيه في مدينه
باخم وبالتالي تطبيق ما تبقى من القوات
الاوكرانيه في المدينه
والصاروخيه الروسيه المستمره على مواقع
القوات الاوكرانيه خلال عمليه تحرير
المدينه دمرت القوه الروسيه 3 طائره حربيه
اوكرانيه ومروحيه وقضت خلال الايام
الثلاثه الماضيه في منطقه السندر على نحو
سبع مئه عسكريين
نشكر كل منا رانيا الدريدي التي كانت معنا
منا موسكو وعمر الحاج ايضا الذي كان معنا
من كرامته